so as we continue our series on Batman
rebirth we pick up now with Batman I am
Gotham the conclusion now something that
I want to point out here is there is a
sixth issue and that sixth issue does
have an epilogue but the issue here is
this epilogue leads directly into I am
suicide and so what we'll do is we're
actually going to postpone that sixth
issue and when we get around to the I am
suicide story arc then we'll use that
six issue to kind of jump off because
what it'll do is it'll allow us to link
both this i''m Gotham story and the I am
suicide story for the new readers who
are coming along at that point in time
but for those of the guys who were just
now jumping on board who were just now
catching up with my video on Batman I am
Gotham we talked about how in previous
videos Gotham City was met with two new
he two new superheroes calling
themselves Gotham and Gotham girl now we
didn't really know who these heroes were
or where they came from we know that
Batman was trying to keep a plane from
crashing into the river he was doing the
best he could to keep that from
happening but in the end Gotham and
Gotham girl were the ones that basically
saved the plane and so from Bruce
Wayne's perspective he didn't initially
trust them but because his I guess their
first impression on him was that they
were acting as heroes he decided to let
them continue without challenging them
and basically learn more about them and
this is what he did he actually went to
their home and once he figured out who
they were and began digging into their
history and what he learned was that
when Hank was a child the name of the
guy Gotham a Hank had basically
encountered that man when Hank and his
parents were held at gunpoint by a
robber in the same fashion that Bruce
Wayne lost his parents and seeing what
was going on Batman had intervened and
he had basically saved the life of Hank
and his parents but because of this Hank
had become obsessed with Batman now
something to point out here is that
Bruce Wayne's interaction with Hank
wasn't necessarily long it was simply
that Bruce had said that the paint that
what he was feeling at the moment was
was fear and that it was okay to be
scared
because everybody gets scared but the
difference between being a hero and
being a coward is that heroes deal with
their fear they come to grips with their
fear and so Bruce Wayne had basically
inspired Hank and Hank himself had
recited this mantra over and over again
that is okay to be scared but you should
always face your fear and had used this
mantra to both inspire his sister Claire
to join him on a journey of bettering
themselves then this was done in a
multitude of different ways uh Hank and
Claire had you know basically train
themselves in physical combat Hank and
Claire had expanded their minds when it
came to forensic science they had travel
the world to become volunteers in a
different I guess a multitude of
different facets they basically
undertaken the same kind of self
training regimen that Bruce Wayne had
taken when he became Batman and so the
result was that during this time they
had reached out to their parents for a
large sum of money and for reasons
unknown or through a means that we
didn't fully understand it was never
really explained to us they emerged some
months later with superpowers now while
we're still not told exactly where those
powers came from in this issue what we
are told is exactly how it works then
what happened is that in the last issue
because of the fact that Gotham had been
manipulated by psycho-pirate a villain
that had the power to manipulate the
emotions of people the psycho-pirate had
basically screwed with Gotham's mind and
ended up putting him in a situation
whereby he had an irrational hatred for
Gotham this was or I guess Gotham City
this was compounded by the fact that one
of the guards one of the soldiers that
Gotham had killed had gone back to the
home of Gotham and murdered his parents
and so because of this this these
manipulations sort of fed in on
themselves to where Gotham had a hatred
of the city and then he had a hatred of
the people in the city because one of
them killed his parents he didn't
realize that he was the cause of his own
problem and so the result here was that
he began traveling back to Gotham City
in order to lay waste to it and Batman
had intended to stop this but because of
the fact that Gotham had fought Batman
directly the Batmobile was destroyed and
Bruce Wayne was left several miles
outside of the city without an immediate
means of return and so what he does is
he asks Alfred to basically intervene on
his behalf to buy some time now of
course Bruce Wayne doesn't actually
expect Alfred to fight as Batman just
because of the fact that Alfred does not
have the combat skills to pull that off
but he is successful in buying time he
approaches Gotham and claims to be
Batman
but because Gotham has various powers he
immediately sees this Bluff but in the
time between when Alfred was bluffing
and when Gotham calls it Batman shows up
and so Alfred takes off and heads back
to the Batcave and Batman and Gotham end
up in a battle
dad basically stretches across the city
of Gotham now Batman tries to reason
with Hank here he tries to tell him
tries to talk him down say hey look man
he can't be carrot here in the city up
we can solve this emotional crisis that
you're having but Gotham is so
entrenched in his anger and so
entrenched in his rage that he just
can't let it go now during this time
because of the fact that Gotham had
killed those soldiers his sister Clara
basically watched the events unfold now
Tom King is not specific here when
Claire was when Claire was found by
Bruce Wayne she was basically just kind
of sitting in the corner in a fetal
position basically saying that she was
scared the reason why I say that Tom
King isn't really clear on this is
because we don't know if if her fear was
a byproduct of you know psycho Pyrus
manipulations or if it was because
Gotham was kind of her backbone he was
the the guy you know the brother that
kept her grounded and kept her confident
and strong but the result is that while
Gotham girl was taken back to the
Batcave and put under the care of both
Duke Thomas and Alfred she's watching
the events unfold both on the news and
through various you know camera devices
the Batman has around Gotham City and so
in the midst of this conflict because
Gotham City is being laid waste to in
such a capacity Duke tries to reason
with her you know Duke tries to talk to
her but she doesn't really want to do
any of that she doesn't really want to
talk to anybody and so what Batman says
is with everything being as chaotic as
it is because of the fact that he cannot
handle Gotham on his own he tells Alfred
to get a hold of the Justice League and
that's exactly what happens in the
intervening moments when things are kind
of going chaotic when Batman's holding
off Gotham as best as he can the Justice
League shows up here of course we have
the pre new 52 Superman
we have Wonder Woman we have Barry Allen
we have Jessica Cruz and Simon Baz the
Green Lanterns of Earth and cyborg and
Aquaman now what's really interesting
about the situation is the Justice
League is a formidable force in and of
themselves I mean they're really the the
cream of the crop when it comes to DC's
earthbound superhero team and of course
with regards to Superman
Wonder Woman and especially Simon - and
Jessica Cruz you know some heroes who
operate beyond the planet Earth who have
the potential to operate beyond the
planet Earth we would expect them to
easily be able to subdue Gotham but this
is not the case Gotham not only power
overpowers a Justice League hue
overpowers Superman now this is
important because this this this is
basically Tom King telling us how
powerful Gotham is in the new 52 the new
52 Superman that we saw when the you
know reboot first launched was weaker
than his pre new 52 counterpart but when
the new 52 Superman was killed and the
pre new 52 Superman took his place we
saw the stronger of the two Superman
emerging this Superman that we see here
is the pre new 52 Superman he's the
strongest version of Superman you know
in the post-crisis on Infinite Earths
continuity and Gotham is easily able to
overpower him now we didn't initially
know what the basis behind this was it
was simply because his powers were just
that much more advanced or if there was
something else going on but this
explanation is given to us by virtue of
Clair of Gotham girl herself and what
she says is that they basically bought
their powers now again we're not given
you know an explanation on where these
powers came from in the story or where
they bought them from we're simply just
told that they bought them and that the
powers they bought were super strength
you know invulnerability ultra vision
but the use of these powers and the
limit of their powers was relative to
their life and what I mean here is they
basically sacrificed years of their life
for higher levels of power and so there
was no limit to how how strong they
could be there was no limit to how
strong Gotham girl or Gotham could be
there was no limit to their
invulnerability there was no limit to
you know how well they could see to
their ultra vision but the higher they
took their powers the more years of
their life they would lose and so if
they wanted to be an ordinary citizen
they could live for decades if they
wanted to be like Superman they would
have to sacrifice a few years of their
life but if they wanted to be godly in
terms of powers they would only have a
few hours to live and so what ended up
happening here is Gotham has basically
pushed his powers to the brink
he has pushed his powers to the extreme
to where they're at their highest levels
or seem to be of the highest levels that
his life can withstand to the point that
he has maybe minute
you know half an hour something like
that left to live and so what Claire
says is that because his power is so
extreme he seems effectively unstoppable
and there really doesn't seem to be a
way to beat him and his goal is to
effectively destroy Gotham City
and so what Batman does is he steps up
here and offers himself to Gotham and
saying that you know that psycho-pirate
was allowed to you know commit his acts
because he hadn't been killed by Batman
that autumns parents were killed because
Batman didn't get there in time and so
he's basically making himself the victim
here Batman would rather Gotham kill him
did wipe out Gotham City at the same
time were given a little bit of a
narrative between Claire and Duke & Duke
says that you know Batman's mantra is
always it's okay to be afraid but you
have to face your fear now this strikes
a chord and Claire because from her
perspective this was not a quote that
you heard from Batman it was a quote she
heard from her brother Hank who of
course got it from Batman and so this is
again basically you know clearing up the
the discussion earlier about how we said
where Tom King wasn't really clear about
you know Gotham girl saying that she was
scared this seems to indicate that
Gotham was kind of her backbone he was
her foundation for the confidence that
she had and the result was that this was
rooted in the idea that Hank would
constantly comfort her and saying it's
okay to be afraid
but you have to face your fear the
result is that once she learns that this
was basically Batman that Batman was the
one that had inspired her to become a
superhero by virtue of inspiring Hank
she immediately takes off to confront
her brother and so for a fraction of a
moment in order to basically keep from
killing herself
Gotham girl puts her powers to the
extreme and in the process of doing so
ends up killing her brother and that
effectively wraps up the story you know
that that sort of brings things to an
end to be honest with the guys this is
kind of this this story was kind of
interesting to me um it really seemed
like Tom King was using this as a
platform to introduce a new superhero in
the form of Gotham girl uh you know I
enjoyed it for what it was I felt like
the the you know the the conspiracy of
the three Joker's really should have
been the first story arc to kind of
bring us in but it also feels like that
would be a trump card just because
that's the one thing that a lot of
people are really looking forward to a
lot of people want to know about the
history of the three Joker's the
conspiracy of the three Joker's and
maybe
have been introducing that in the
beginning would have just been too soon
you know maybe it was something better
suited for two or three story arcs down
the line which seems to be what DC is
going for but the fact remains that you
know this story being what it is it's a
it's it's a good story for rebirth I
don't think it's one of the Batman
stories but it's pretty solid but if you
guys enjoyed this supposed to comment
down below let me know what you guys
think about this story you know what
your opinions are again if you guys are
not part of the robb core hit the
subscribe button and if you guys enjoyed
this video drop a like and yeah I will
catch you guys later peace
[Music]